[MUSIC PLAYING]
EDD WILDER-JAMES:
Hey, everybody.
How you doing?
Good.
Excellent.
That was an amazing set
of demos, wasn't it?
So I work with
TensorFlow, helping
build community
and collaboration
around the open source project.
And usually, I put the
thank you slide at the end,
for listening to me.
But actually, I want to thank
you for contributing and being
part of the TensorFlow project.
Whether you're here in this
room or on the livestream--
there's been some amazing
talk on YouTube from people
in China, and India, and Japan,
and all over the world joining
us virtually today--
thank you for your
contributions.
The project is where it
is today because of you.
Of course, in core
TensorFlow alone, we've
had this many commits.
Now this figure is out
of date-- over 50,000
from 1,800 contributors,
and much more than just code
commits.
There's been 39,000
Stack Overflow
questions about TensorFlow.
We have 66 machine learning
Google Developer Experts,
many of whom are
here with us today.
So welcome, and thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
It's really great
to have you with us.
And thank you for
everything you do helping
teach people about TensorFlow.
And we've had 14 guest posts
to the TensorFlow blog,
and that keeps going up.
There are so many ways that
people are contributing.
Whether you're organizing
a meetup, whether you're
teaching other people, whether
you're speaking at conferences,
thank you.
You're really helping build
out the TensorFlow ecosystem.
So in this talk,
what I want to do
is discuss how we're
growing the ecosystem
and report back on
some of the changes
that we've made
over the last year.
So I'm going to cover how
we're making it easier
to get involved in TensorFlow.
How, also, we're trying
to consult better
with the users in
the community and be
more transparent
about our development.
I'm going to cover how
we're empowering everybody
to get involved, and to
do more, and increasing
the number of contact
points where you can
get involved in the project.
Finally, I'm going to
go into a bit more depth
about the conference that
was announced this morning,
the TensorFlow World.
So let's talk about how we're
making contribution easier
to TensorFlow.
One of the most
important things to help
people contribute to the project
is increasing its modularity.
You heard Martin
talk, this morning,
about the low-level APIs.
And with the move
to TensorFlow 2.0,
we're trying to make it
less of a monolith, both
in terms of code and in
terms of people organization.
When you come and you want to
contribute to an open source
project, it helps to be able
to find where to contribute
and who to work with.
By splitting things out, we're
creating more surface area
where it's easy to start
building and creating
new projects.
And our special interest
groups play a big part in this,
and I'll talk a bit
more about them later.
But it's not just code.
There's so many more places to
contribute this year, compared
to where we were last year.
So I'm going to talk briefly
about our documentation
groups, the groups
getting involved
in testing, people who are
blogging, and on YouTube,
and more.
I was super excited
to see, last week,
that we have published a
TensorFlow tutorial now
in Korean.
And that's not a translation
that we've done on our team,
but that has come
from the community.
So thank you so much to Hasin
Park for the Korean work.
Similarly, we're able, also,
to publish it in Russian.
Thank you to Andrew Steppen.
This is just so exciting,
to see that TensorFlow
is being taken to more
areas around the world,
thanks to you.
I'm also really excited about
the TensorFlow 2.0 testing
group.
Led by Paige Bailey,
this is a bunch
of contributors and
Google Developer
Experts who are working to give
TensorFlow 2.0 a thorough test.
And you see, on the screen,
an example of a friction log.
And so what's happening
here is that folks
are going through ML
workflows with TensorFlow 2.0,
documenting what they find
delightful and awesome,
and also things that could
be a little bit better.
If you'd like to
join in this work,
this group meets weekly
and often has guests talks
from maintainers, and
SIG leaders, and so on,
and is really helping
bring TensorFlow 2.0
from the cutting edge into
something that is thoroughly
tested and ready for use.
Already mentioned,
we have over 14 posts
from guests on the
TensorFlow blog.
This is from a great post about
realtime person segmentation
in the browser
with TensorFlow.js.
It comes from a grad student
and researcher and ITP.
So whether it's testing,
whether it's documentation,
whether it's blogs and
conference talks, thank you.
Now I want to talk a little
bit about TensorFlow RFCs.
As you probably know, RFC
means Request For Comments.
This time last year, we
weren't that organized
about how we evolved
TensorFlow's design,
in terms of communicating it.
And I stood on this
stage and told you
about how we were going
to launch the RFC process.
Well, now we've accepted
21 RFCs over the period
of the last year.
This is our key way to
communicate design, where
before code gets
landed in the project,
we post an RFC about the
design and consult widely.
This isn't just
about code that's
coming in from the TensorFlow
core team outwards.
They can be created and
commented on by anyone.
We've had several RFCs that
come from the broader community.
And I expect to see so many
more of those in the future.
We have several, for instance,
from. the SIG groups already.
One of the things
I'm most proud about
is how the RFC process
is underpinning
the 2.0 transition.
This was mentioned earlier,
but all the major changes
in TensorFlow 2.0 have
been proposed and consulted
with in RFCs.
This isn't just a great way
of consulting and getting
information feedback.
Going forward, you now
have a big repository
of technical documentation about
why design choices were made
a certain way in TensorFlow.
And it's a great educational
resource, as well,
for people who are coming
on and want to get involved
in contributing to the project.
So I really want to
give a big thanks
to anyone who has authored
or reviewed an RFC.
You've played a vital role
in making TensorFlow better.
Now let's talk a bit about the
social structure of TensorFlow.
Last year I talked about how
coming to a large project
can be a little bit daunting.
You don't know where
people are, where
the people that have your
interests in common are.
And so we created the Special
Interest Groups, or SIGs,
as a way of organizing our work.
There are so many
uses of TensorFlow,
so many environments,
so many architectures.
And many of them are
outside of the scope
that the core team can resource.
And what we wanted to
do was enable TensorFlow
to grow and be more
sustainable by creating
a way for like-minded
people to collaborate
around well-defined projects.
So this is why SIGs exist.
They're groups of people
who are working together
for a defined project focus.
We started last
year with SIG Build,
and now we have six of
them up and running.
I'm going to give you a
quick state of the SIGs.
Many-- in fact, most--
of all the SIG leaders
are here with us
today as well, so I'll
give a shout-out to them.
And hopefully, you'll also
be able to talk to them
in the lunch and tomorrow.
So SIG Addons first--
thank you to Shaun Morgan
and Amanda Fandango
for leading this group.
Martin mentioned, at the
beginning of the day,
that tf.contrib is no
longer a part of TensorFlow
going into TensorFlow 2.0.
And SIG Addons is a place where
a lot of that code is going.
So these are parts of TensorFlow
that don't fall into the core,
but do conform to these
well-defined APIs--
so more losses, ops,
layers, and so on.
Now there's already
an RFC published
about where you can
find things that you
used to find in contrib
that have gone into addons.
And addons are also going to
publish another RFC real soon
to say, well, how
can you get involved,
if you have your
favorite app or whatever,
that you want to step
up and be a maintainer,
and maintain it
for everybody, how
you can join in the project.
So I'd encourage you
to take a look at that.
SIG Build-- SIG Build
really is where TensorFlow
meets the outside world.
And it's not always the most
glamorous piece of work,
but building TensorFlow,
and packaging it,
and distributing it is tough.
And so thank you so much
to Jason Ziman and Austin
Anderson, who lead that SIG.
SIG Build has achieved a
lot in the last few months.
One thing, it's the
home for third-party
contributed builds
for architectures
that we don't ship
out as part of core--
so IBM Power, Intel
MKL optimized builds.
And SIG Build works on
improving the TensorFlow build
and helps us be a better
neighbor in the Python
ecosystem as well.
As you can imagine,
machine learning
generates a lot of
extreme situations
that need changes in ways
we evolve in packaging
and distributing software.
SIG IO is a fantastic group
that helps connect TensorFlow
to other systems.
Out in the real world,
your data exists somewhere.
You're using other
systems in other formats.
So this group is led by Yong
Tang and Anton Dimitriev.
IO really ships support for
extra file systems, extra file
formats.
So if you're using any of these
things in the Apache ecosystem
or any of these
file formats, you
can use the SIG Addons module
to use that data in TensorFlow.
This group is prolific.
They've already
dropped four releases.
Last week, they just
created their 0.4 release.
And they also ship R integration
with their module too.
SIG Networking is where a lot
of the alternative networking
schemes that are available
in contrib are going to.
This is led by Byron
Yi and Jeron Bedoff.
So if you're using
GDR, VERBS, MPI,
this is where you can find that.
SIG Rust, led by Adam Crume, is
developing idiomatic language
bindings for the Rust
programming language.
If you're interested in this,
or any of the other SIGs,
please talk to the leaders.
They really do want more help.
And now they're up and running,
they're in a great place
to bring people on.
If you're looking
for a way to get
involved in contributing
to TensorFlow,
this is an ideal one.
Finally, let me touch
on SIG TensorBoard.
We've rebooted SIG
TensorBoard this year
to really work closely
with the community.
And so this is a great time to
be involved, as the TensorBoard
team are starting to consult
and figuring out how we can best
enable people who are
using TensorBoard,
both in terms of creating
plugins or using it at scale.
If you go to the demo area
above and go to the TensorBoard
stand, you'll find
Mani and Gal there,
who will be happy
to talk to you.
So this is the URL
for anything you
want to do with
joining the TensorFlow
community, from docs,
to testing, to SIGs,
and all the other
ways to be involved,
the developer mailing list.
Please head there.
And if you're here with us
rather than on the livestream,
we're doing a contributor
luncheon tomorrow,
where there'll be a little panel
discussion about contributing
to TensorFlow.
And many of the core
team and the SIG leaders
will be there to talk to you.
So finally, let's move on and
talk about TensorFlow World.
I'm so excited about this.
It's our vision to bring
together the amazing people who
are part of our community
and give a space for everyone
to connect with each other.
You know, there's
so much we can all
learn from how we're all
working with TensorFlow.
So working with
O'Reilly Media, we're
going to have this event at
the end of October this year,
here in Santa Clara.
It'll be four days that really
celebrate the TensorFlow
ecosystem.
We'll have content from
talks to tutorials.
There'll be an expo and a
place for vendors to present.
So we understand, as TensorFlow
gets out into the real world,
there is a large ecosystem
beyond folks in this room.
And we're really excited
that that means that we
can bring everyone together.
You know, the main
point of doing something
like this is to connect all
the amazing users and everyone
with experience to share.
As you heard, the call
for proposals is now open.
So if you have anything
to share with your work,
your product, your company,
head to TensorFlow World.
Put in a proposal.
You've got about
four or five weeks,
while the call for
proposals is open.
And then we'll be selecting
talks a few weeks after that.
I really hope that you will
lend your voice to this event,
and I'm so excited to
see you all in October.
So once again, thank you.
We really appreciate
how much that you
are a part of our community.
Honestly, in my job, the
best thing, every day,
is when I get to talk to folks
who are using or developing
TensorFlow.
And I know that's the same
for everyone on the team.
It really is so exciting to
work with everybody here.
This is the way you can meet me.
Please do.
If you have any
issue, or any desire
to contribute, or get involved
with the community, reach out.
We're really happy
to talk to you.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]